hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn
in today's topic we will understand how
exactly a hacker gets their information
well to
understand this
for example if somebody wants to hack
into a company
they definitely had to get some of the
information or in-depth knowledge or
in-depth data regarding the company
but how is it done
this is when google docking works
through google docking we can get some
of the insider views that are
accidentally made public on the internet
well to better understand let's dive in
for today's agenda we'll understand what
exactly is google docking
and whether is it legal to practice
google docking
and lastly some of the search operators
which can be used for docking
google docking is a way to utilize a
google search engine to search for
different types of data and information
that is generally not available for
public view this is done by using
docking operators which is also the
reason why google docking is often
termed as google hacking
let's continue forward and know whether
the docking is illegal or illegal
using the working techniques to see data
information on google is not an eagle
practice
if it is done for the research or
practical knowledge but if the obtained
data through docking is used for
malicious purpose
then it becomes an illegal act
punishable by law
now that we understand some general
information about google docking let's
take a look at the operators
the first operator is a site operator
this operator searches for a specific
site that we refer to
then we have in url it is used for a
specific keyword in the url of the site
then we have in title which is used to
search for a defined heading in the
webpage
and similarly to entitle the in-text
operator is used to search for a
specific keyword in the body section of
the web page
and in the end we have file type as the
name suggests
using file type operator we can search
for a particular type of file for
example a pdf file or a log file on the
internet
well this is all about the theoretical
knowledge
but it's better to have an understanding
through demo
so let's begin
well to start with let's access a google
chrome
to begin with let's firstly type the
site operator
which
defines the type of site that we want to
access
for example
simplylearn.com
through this operator
as we can see we get all the sites that
are related to simply learn
this is the way we can use site operator
we can also search for some other site
for example amazon.com
through this we get only the sites that
are
related to amazon
now let's try the second one
which is in url operator
pin url operators allow us to search for
a specific keyword that we see often on
the urls
let's search for admin url
now as we can see we have different
types of sites
but
each of them has admin in them
this is the work that can be done by
using the operator in url
let's not try the in title operator
in title operator as the name suggests
can be used to search for a specific
keyword in the title of the webpage for
example
french press
now as we can see
the french press
and that is available in the in title
that is the title of the web page and we
get only
the search where french press is
included
now let's do something
interesting using the in title
let's search for webcams
well this is something really
interesting i guess
webcam
xp
five
let's see
okay so we get some of the searches that
are related to webcams
let's try accessing one of them
okay now we can see like some of the
public webcams that are available on the
internet
that can access real view
well guys can you see the cars moving
that means this is real time view webcam
let's try changing the source
as we can see
this is a live view from some of the
public webcams that are either not
protected or are available on the
internet
the point to be noted is if you want to
research all this
that's fine but we shouldn't use all the
search operations from google docking
for any illegal purpose
well let's continue with our operators
and start with
in text
as the name suggests intex can be used
to search for a specific keyword in a
large amount of data available on a web
page let's search for keyword
process
well as we can see
the web page that are related to our
process
and they are randomly generated it's not
in a
procedure so i guess
we can get
process
so this is how you can utilize the
in-text
operator
and the last operator we have is
file type operator
file type operator as the name suggest
can be used to search for a specific
type of file on the web
let's try searching for
pdf files
but before that we have to mention some
place where the pdf would be from for
example
amazon
let's see the result
by the result we can see that the type
of file we got is pdf file
and the related is amazon
let's try accessing some of them
okay seems like some financial result
and see your transaction file
and that's to in pdf that we mentioned
in the file type
and this is how you can access any of
the file type we mentioned like
external files enb files password files
or different types of log files
now
from this we understand the operators in
itself cannot exactly search for
specific data that can be used for
hacking
but what if we combine different
operators and search for a new one
well this is definitely interesting idea
and let's try accessing this
let's try
with site
as
amazon
and
for in title
we should type
admin
let's see what will the result be
seems like we have some of the sites
which are related to administration
and
amazon.com
and once again guys this is all just for
research purpose
let's try mixing some other
operators also
what about if we
use
site
or should i say in text let's try and
text
in text as username and
file type as log file
let's see the result
let's try visiting some of the links we
got from the result
this looks like to be some of a log file
of a website
username
and the log file type
seems like this log file has some
username and password related to some of
the websites
this is how hackers research data before
they
try to access somebody else's
information
different types of log data
well now that we understand that
combining different types of operators
can give us different results
let's try one more to better understand
this
let's use
site
as
starbucks
a famous
brand starbucks.com
and
what about using in text
as
passwords
let's try
well seems like we have the result
according to this
i think we accessed into how passwords
can be used in
for
starbucks
guide to starbucks and everything is
related to that
well guys this is how we can use google
doc means like the operators are
different and combining different
operators we can get different search
results
but instead if we want to search for
specific data and are confused about the
operator mixing we can also search for
google
hacking
database
it a database that we can use to access
different types of
operators
using in title
in url
in url and site
you can use this for reference
with this we can conclude our
demo on google docking
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section
and subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update from
us thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here